[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité et irina
bénédicte au vhc la procureur général
d'ukraine elle est avec nous depuis la
capitale ukrainienne kiev merci d'être
avec nous au genoa je remercie beaucoup
chers amis merci de me recevoir sur
votre plateforme l'offensive militaire
russe a débuté dans l'est du pays dans
le donbass après ce qu'on a découvert
autour de kiev notamment abuja est ce
que vous pensez que des crimes
similaires vont être découverts à mario
paul ou dans le reste du donbass il faut
speak about nous parlons de mario
pouliot paul se trouve dans le donbass
explique
donc je pense que nous allons découvrir
qu'il y aura des chiffres de plus en
plus important était clair de plus en
plus graves je comprends bien ceci parce
que maintenant nous disposons déjà de
chiffre de victimes civiles
d'enfants et ceux ci ne compte pas mario
paul ne savons pas exactement ce qui se
passe dans la ville de marie-paule c'est
la raison pour laquelle
lorsque nous sortirons de marioupol
lorsqu'elle ne sera plus occupée une
nouvelle ronde des exemples de crime à
grande échelle
et ce ne sera pas seulement des crimes
de guerre ou des crimes contre
l'humanité je pense que nous allons
trouver en tout cas je m'attends à
trouver des éléments preuve de génocide
et bien évidemment nous devons tous
vérifiés faire en sorte que notre
mécanisme d'investigation de vérifier
par ailleurs nous sommes maintenant
confrontés à une situation qui est très
difficile non seulement dans la région
ont tenté d'embrasser de lougansk
par exemple une cartier feu ces deux
villes sont encore pilonné sont encore
bombardée et c'est la raison pour
laquelle tout l'est de l'ukraine
maintenant se trouve en très grand
danger
on a des informations j'ai parlé à votre
ministre des affaires étrangères que la
russie a amené des crématoriums mobile à
marioupol
possiblement pour cacher les preuves des
crimes qu'on a trouvé aboud chabot
rhodia est ce que c'est les remontées de
terrain que vous avez également
c'est tout à fait possible je dispose
des mêmes informations
remontées du terrain sur l'utilisation
de ces crématorium et le nombre de
victimes va s'avérer si élevé c'est
encore une fois peut-être ils sont en
train de brûler des cadavres maintenant
mais nous allons découvrir un très grand
nombre d'actifs supplémentaires
vous venez de parler des gens qui ont
disparu de ce pied votre ambassadeur
auprès des nations unies a affirmé que
plus de 500 milles ukrainien avait été
déporté de force vers la russie dont
plus de 120 mille enfants est ce que ce
sont également les chiffres que vous
avez
ces chiffres en effet encore une fois
nous utilisons ces informations du point
de vue opérationnel et puisque je suis
procureur je ne peux pas donner les
chiffres avant à voir que nous en ayons
terminé toutes les enquêtes mais ce que
nous avons maintenant nous avons ces
territoires qui sont en combat la
plupart sont occupés et c'est pour ça
qu'on ne pouvons pas mené une autre
enquête sur le terrain mais nous
comprenons qu'il y a nous ou des
chiffres énormes de civils déplacés
d'ukraine vers la russie beaucoup
d'enfants parmi ceux là et nous ne
savons pas réellement ce qui se passe
maintenant et où sont ses enfants
bien évidemment nous comprenons que nous
pouvons pas commencer
à traduire les suspects en justice ou
même de mener les enquêtes à proprement
parler que quand nous serons sur le
terrain nous devons d'abord assurer la
victoire dans cette fière et ensuite
nous commencerons à punir les coupables
les zones où vous avez accès sont celles
autour de kiev notamment évidemment
lucha libre au dunk à combien de morts
avez vous pu trouver identifiés et parmi
eux les enfants dès qu'elles sont le
vole chiffres les derniers chiffres
étaient de 15 sont
civils tués le nombre d'enfants
parmi ceux ci je devrais le vérifier
mais nous avons bien d'autres
territoires dans la région de kiev qui
sont encore miné c'est pourquoi nous ne
pouvons pas avoir les chiffres exacts
pour la région de kiev
même si elle n'est plus occupé
maintenant donc pauvre pas des mines et
tous les territoires de la région autour
de kiev nous sommes encore en train de
le faire qu'en est il des crimes sexuels
il ya des informations selon lesquelles
ils ont eu lieu à bou cha et ailleurs qu
avez-vous trouvé ce que nous avons
découvert malheureusement c'est que des
crimes à caractère sexuel ont été
perpétrés dans tous les territoires
occupés les territoires qui sont
maintenant occupés nous avons des cas de
victimes concrètes avec lesquels nous
pour vous parler mais vous savez que les
gens sont encore tellement stressés
qu'ils sont parfois pas en mesure de
parler par ailleurs nous avons beaucoup
d'informations pratiques de prêtres de
mer de journalistes sur le terrain
sec ce qui corrobore ces crimes à
caractère sexuel et qu'il n'était pas
perpétré seulement à l'encontre de
femmes mais aussi à l'encontre d'hommes
d'enfants et même dans certains cas de
crimes à caractère sexuel contre les
femmes âgées
c'est pourquoi encore une fois je
voudrais dire ceci quand nous aurons les
chiffres
nozomi je crois au final un nombre très
élevé de crimes à caractère sexuel parce
que ça va pas ça se passe dans tous les
territoires en guerre qu'elle conçoit le
pays ou la région de la planète
tout d'abord un état doit gagner la
guerre est ensuite assurer la sécurité
des victimes avant que nous puissions
parler et après ça le système juridique
doit traiter les cas les traduire en
justice et les victimes nous parlons
bien d'en quête avez vous ouvert depuis
le début de la guerre
c'est un très grand nombre maintenant le
total je crois de crimes de guerre et de
crimes liés à des crimes de guerre
est de plus de 10 min à plus de 7000
investigations sur des crimes de guerre
et trois mille sur des crimes liés à des
crimes de guerre ce sont des chiffres
énormes
nombreux donc être menée malheureusement
tous les jours nous avons encore deux
nouveaux cas
sur lequel nous devons lancer des
enquêtes dans la région des rares qui
veut nous avons des bombardements sur
des civils des bombardements de cibles
civiles chaque fois qu'il y a de nouveau
fait nous lançons une nouvelle enquête
qui visait vous de simple soldat des
mercenaires ou des jambes un plus haut
niveau
c'est une excellente question il faut
qu'un celle ci
je puis dire nous ciblons tous les
criminels potentiels tous ceux qui ont
perpétré des crimes de guerre en ukraine
nous avons entendu de la part des
prisonniers de guerre ici en ukraine que
eux ne sont pas des combattants ce ne
sont pas des militaires à proprement
parler
et ont tous tuer des civils bombardé des
cibles civiles ou ont confisqué les
propriétés de civils kleenex ont
perpétré d'autres crimes donc ce sont
des gens qui ont commis ces crimes même
s'ils ne sont pas des militaires et par
ailleurs nous avons des nombre très
élevé d'agressions
d'agression menée par la fédération de
russie à l'encontre de l'ukraine ya
maintenant nous avons près de 600
suspect il s'agit ici de politiciens de
haut niveau de la fédération de russie
de militaires de très haut grade d'agent
de propagande par exemple le ministre de
la défense shaoul par exemple ministre
de l'intérieur kolokoltsev et je
comprends que ce grand nombre de
suspects
devraient être tenus responsables de
l'agression de l'ukraine et ça se montra
après 2002 pour y compris vladimir
poutine lui-même
est le personnage le plus influent dans
la fédération de russie bien évidemment
il est responsable ou le de tout ce qui
a été fait au nom de la fédération de
russie mais selon la législation
ukrainienne
experts d'une mise en oeuvre la
législation nationale le droit
humanitaire et le droit international
le président le ministre des affaires
étrangères et le premier ministre selon
la législation dite nationale dispose de
l'immunité c'est la raison pour laquelle
je veux travailler en étroite
collaboration et je suis tout à fait
ouverte à une coopération
avec le procureur
la compagnie à l'international parce que
les institutions internationales ne
reconnaissent pas cette impunité
d'accord mais vous souhaitez que ces cas
soient jugés dans votre pays ou
à la cour pénale internationale dont
vous venez parler ou ailleurs comme lui
sommes disposés à collaborer avec
d'autres états
d'ailleurs en ce moment
l'ukraine a lancé une enquête avec 13
autres états sur les crimes de guerre
perpétrés en ukraine et par ailleurs
nous avons des équipes d'investigation
conjointe avec la pologne et la lituanie
à travers la plateforme d'eurojust donc
nous faisons ceci conjointement et pour
moi en tant que procureur général
d'ukraine il est très important
d'avoir des décisions qui sont prises
par les tribunaux l'ukrainien où une
coulée juge nommé par le crâne j'aime
mon pays j'ai confiance en ses
institutions
et je veux faire tout ce qui est en
bonne voie
pour réussir
mais par ailleurs je suis tout à fait
ouverte à toute collaboration avec
d'autres procureurs d'autres
institutions internationales
est ce que c'est un génocide qui se
déroule en ukraine il ya eu une dispute
entre les présidents français et votre
président le président français dit
qu'il ne veut pas utiliser ce mot le
président zelensky affirmé qu'il a été
blessé par cela de votre point de vue
d'un point de vue légal est ce qu ont
atteint le seuil du génocide
initié une investigation sur le chef
d'accusation de génocide les premiers
jours de la guerre nous avons traduit en
justice des individus
sur base de faits concrets
selon lequel des agents de propagande
russe avait écrit des livres sur la
dénazification de l'ukraine et qu'il
parlait d'un génocide à l'encontre des
ukrainiens mais par ailleurs le
président zelensky et notre chef d'état
et il comprend très bien que la
fédération ou de russie et que les
militaires russes maintenant veulent
détruire non seulement notre état en
tant qu'etat mais veulent également
détruire la population ils veulent tuer
les ukrainiens ils veulent faire en
sorte que notre dame nation
disparaissent comme un écho un événement
historique et le président zelensky a
dit que en tant que chef d'état de son
pays il a déclaré et moi je suis
procureur et je fais tout ce qui est en
mon pouvoir pour essayer de trouver les
éléments de preuve qui permette de
trouver l'existence de ce crime à grande
échelle après quoi je vous donnerai mes
conclusions irina bénédicte va merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux questions
de france 24 et merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cette édition sur nos antennes
[Musique]